Pope Francis is wrapping up his two-day
unity tour of Egypt by celebrating Mass
at a stadium in Cairo this morning the
pontiff has been reaching out to Muslims
and the Coptic Christian community
following the recent attacks on two of
its churches security has remained a
major concern Seth Doane has more from
Rome Seth good morning good morning on
this trip the Pope has emphasized
interfaith dialogue Brotherhood and has
called for an end to religious violence
despite security risks the pontiff drove
in an open popemobile this morning
before Mass in a stadium and he stopped
to hug kids dressed up as ancient
Egyptians but it was this embrace
between Pope Francis and the grand Imam
of el sofá on Friday that showcased the
main message of this mission unity of
religions at al-assad considered an
important center of learning in Sunni
Islam the Pope spoke out against the
barbarity of religious extremism he
cried shout that out those who are
different the Pope noted either
culturally or religiously should not be
seen or treated as enemies the Pope has
tried out a little Arabic on this trip
as how am i regularly wishing
assalamualaikum or peace be with you to
his Arab audience threats of violence
are clear in the heavy security that has
accompanied Pope Francis on each stop of
his 27 hour journey the trip comes after
a series of attacks on Egypt's Christian
minority including twin church bombings
on Palm Sunday which killed 45 people
Isis claimed responsibility the Pope
also prayed at a Cathedral where 29
people were killed in December in a
suicide bombing and he met with Egyptian
president Abdel Fattah al-sisi
who welcomed Francis's message of hope
and peace which was underlined with
posters hung in Egypt's capital the Pope
also sends a message in the car he is
driven in in this case a small Fiat
witches unarmored and Anthony at times
he's rolled down the window to greet
passers-by in his way of appearing a
little close
to the people well Seth Doane in Rome
Thank You Seth